try to pause the video and figure out
what 71 plus 24 is
all right now let's do this together so
let's think about what 71 actually means
well we have a one in the ones place let
me make this clear so this is the ones
place
and so we have one one and so that's
that one one right over there and then
in the tens place in the tens place
we have seven and so we have seven
groups of ten
one two three four five six seven groups
of ten so this this really means seven
tens and one one this right over here is
71 boxes
and we're going to add to that
two tens
we're going to add to that two tens you
see them here one ten two tens and four
ones
and four
ones so what is that going to be
well let's first think about let's think
first thing let's think about the ones
we have one one and then four more ones
well that's going to be five ones
that's going to be five ones so we can
count them right over there that is five
ones right over there one one plus four
ones
is five ones
and then when you look at the tens
seven tens
plus two tens well if you combine all of
these together
if you combine all of these together you
are going to have nine of these groups
of ten you're going to have nine tens
seven tens plus two tens is nine tens so
we're left with nine tens which we see
right over here and five ones
and five ones
well what's another way of saying nine
tens and five ones well that's 95 and
we're done